notre leader bien aimé a pris tout le
monde par surprise en annonçant sa
candidature aux prochaines élections
présidentielles sous sa dictature
condamnés n'ont connu de souffrir toute
fraude relevés par les observateurs
internationaux entraînera l'application
de sanctions je veux que vous alliez au
gondwana pour porter haut le flambeau de
la tradition démocratique de votre pays
partir une semaine en afrique république
très très démocratique du gondwana
je voudrais rejoindre mes collègues fait
partie de la mission des observateurs
non juste citoyen helvète est revenue se
passe par là alors comme ça vous êtes
devenu surviennent aux élections des
loyers pas comme ça mais observons et
rendons compte la communauté
internationale vous avez dit communauté
internationale ça tombe bien il ya
autant qu on vous attendait c'est dieu
vous avez tous les pays tiers sont là et
le président du conseil économique et
social aux anneaux président de la cour
des comptes comme ça
on en a pas beaucoup plus si tant il a
dit faites jusqu'à quand
accepteriez vous de jouer les idiots
utiles de nos dictatures qui sont en
train de tout organiser pour voler des
élections nocioni 6 pandémie pas de
procès d'intention
j'ai découvert de quoi faire tomber
votre président fondateur
on est fatigués majorité opposition ils
sont tous les mêmes je suis l'oppose à
limay lorrain de ce pays à l'est d'hilla
président fondateur du jamais il
marchera avec de l'argent volé c'est ça
on est un tout petit salut ça fait mal
et quand tu vas gagner les élections
tout pour ban aux oubliettes
[Musique]